[Music]
shortly before the chauvin verdict was
announced hundreds of people had
gathered at the site where george floyd
was murdered
in south minneapolis the memorial known
as george
floyd square honors him and the movement
that he inspired
yesterday before the verdict we went
there we met janelle austin
she's one of the site's caretakers what
makes this
this unique you know it's become a kind
of profound
space where people still pay respect we
started our conversation at the say
their name cemetery
it memorializes black americans killed
by police
the power of the installation is that
there are so many names that we don't
know
and it challenges us to look up their
names
learn their story so that they're not
forgotten the 100 headstones
a place for people to grieve what does
it look like for us to create
public spaces where people whenever they
are experiencing their loss
they can come here and the space is big
enough to hold their grief
we then walked around the corner to the
infamous site where george floyd was
killed
from barricades of barricades dorsal
edge square so on june 1st you came here
and did what you said you
you took it upon yourself to preserve it
yeah and what did that mean when you
said i want to preserve this what were
you doing
i was literally picking up trash and
straightening up flowers this is
originally where
the community had built an offering to
acknowledge where his body had laid
but during the trial as i was watching
i noticed that we got the spot wrong and
so i
actually measured out where it was and
we
relayed where his body had laid with
flowers right there that gives me chills
janelle
that gives me chills because it's
important that we remember the story
correctly
and what is the story you want to make
sure that we remember one
that a man was lynched in our community
two
that it was a city employee on city time
who did it
three that the community came together
and said
not in our backyard and we also
recognize that there are conditions
in the context of our community that led
to this incident
and we want those addressed
now janelle alston explained to us that
the memorials are a former protest
because they are disruptive
and she wants that space to be a place
for people to come and express
themselves
however they want to do that whether
it's through prayer protest
art or leaving memorials to george floyd
there are a lot of those there